he said some things about habib no  magametto we got a bunch of russians  here guess what those russians got him  in the bathroom because he was in the  song like four or five of them and they  told him hey brother you cannot talk  like this he's like no i'm sorry i'm  apologetic yourself so listen  how you feel about muslims tell them i  have nothing but love and respect for  every muslim in the world and and  anybody that wants to your viewpoints or  your viewpoints and i would never judge  anybody for what they believe in and i  have nothing but love for everybody in  respect so you don't have nothing  against the muslims hell yeah much love  and respect to the muslims i respect all  you guys and what you guys believe in  foreign